August in labus is usually a month when
Anglers Prosper but not this August for
along the river order more than 10 tons
of fish have been killed something
unheard of for people living here
I have been fishing here for 40 years
and have never experienced anything like
this on this scale it gives me
goosebumps when I see how many dead fish
there are here in the order
official advice is for people to stay
away from the river while the
authorities establish what is killing
the fish
as of today no water tests have
confirmed the presence of toxic
substances at the same time we're
conducting tests on fish for mercury and
heavy metals these were not found in the
collected samples the river order marks
the frontier between Poland and Germany
it flows for nearly 900 kilometers to
the Baltic Sea and plays hosts to a
delicate ecosystem
uh it is clear that we are facing a
really bad environmental catastrophe
that has at least resulted in a serious
amount of dead fish we do not know yet
how long and how extensive the
environmental impacts will be in the
ecosystem or in the next week's months
or years although an investigation is
well underway into what caused so many
fish to Die In this River it has to be
said that on the German side of the
order there are some voices asking
questions about the speed and the size
of the operation on the Polish side of
the border to find out what's caused
these deaths it seems the Polish
government has heard those voices the
heads of Poland's Water Authority and
environment inspectorates have been
sacked the view in Warsaw is that
someone may have deliberately put a
toxic substance into the river which is
why a reward of more than two hundred
thousand dollars has been offered for
help in finding who did this Dominic
Kane Al jazeer error on the order River
well Linda Marie muchler is the
coordinator of an international River
order protection project for friends of
the earth Germany and she believes
environmental factors contributed to
death
there has never in my life been such a
cure instead so many fish died over such
a short time we
environmental organizations say or we
think that there are different stresses
on the fish that come together and that
then there can be one factor causing
such an Extinction so at the moment we
have very high temperatures in Germany
and recording of high air growth of
unusual oxygen levels of very low water
levels and the fish are not used to
these kind of conditions in Germany so
if there's a poisoning then this can be
one factor too much we talk now of
several tons of fish that have been
collected over several hundred
kilometers in the river if you have seen
the images it's really horrible and a
lot of people collecting these fish at
the moment and a lot of fear that it can
go to the Baltic Sea and then also cause
a very high damage there and we actually
now have this task force set up by the
German and by the Polish Ministry and
um I hope that they will find out more